they took everything from us
cause magic
run this through us so Katherine this
show I love the concept right from the
start it's a twist on who grabs the
sword a woman gets it she's a goddess a
queen a warrior what drew you to this
project was that a huge part of it I
mean yeah everything you just mentioned
growing up of a fan of fantasy and also
a fan of history I mean the Arthurian
legends whether you're a fan of either
of those things or not it's something
that's just so familiar and ingrained
within our within our literature and our
folklore but it's also something where
you know we hear that and we think of
King Arthur and Merlin and the knights
of the round table we're very familiar
with the male characters but we very
seldom if ever dive into the stories of
the women particularly you know the
prolific and powerful lady of the lake
who is such an icon in the Arthurian
legends we really know very little to
nothing about her so to be able to have
the opportunity to tell her story but I
think also placed a woman at the
epicenter of this legendary tale it just
feels so timely and it was such an
exciting opportunity to be a part of so
as a fan of fantasy how did you feel
about getting to wield the sword and get
the makeup and everything was that a lot
of fun I loved it yeah my inner nerd for
sure would like more my inner child was
thriving and quite often Tom wheeler and
I we would kind of like go off the side
to sit and just like this is so cool
because it is it's so amazing to be able
to do this as a job but also I have to
say it was an incredible learning
experience because you know as a fan of
these genres we often see these amazing
epic pieces and I think with the
popularity of them in the past couple of
years of past decade the bar is set so
high and being a part of telling this
kind of story it really opened my eyes
to see just how much work it takes not
just in terms of you know like time and
and rehearsing and putting the acting
together but also the fact that you know
you've got to learn a vast skill set in
a short period of time you shoot for
like a year and I can't get injured and
I can't get sick and we're moving to
locations like I think my driver's ed
incredible one of the toughest days we
heard is when he picked me up in England
or UK in England a big kind of in London
sorry that was a quite broad they picked
me up from London at 3:45 in the morning
so we could get to Wales and then we
shot a whole day and and finished the
day and it was those kinds of things and
that kind of teamwork which just really
impressed me and I'm so proud of
everyone on this what was it like I mean
the show is all about who can grab that
sword what was it like for you the first
time you did it it was really
interesting actually because like I said
everything that you say on this is made
by hand it's custom-made including the
weapons and when I was first trying out
swords you know there was a lot of
debate what this is the sword of power
we how do we you know how big is it were
like what does it look like what is on
it and the armor was handing me like
okay so this is Russell Crowe's sword
from this thing and this is Chris Pines
from this thing and this is Timothy
shell amazed and it was just it was a
moment where I kind of like a comment
that was me or someone else went like oh
like one day someone's gonna be like oh
this is like Kathryn so like a woman saw
it he is like this person sword playing
a queen because I had only been picking
up swords of kings and knights and all
that kind of thing so to just have that
and feel the power of I don't know just
being a heroine and being able to you
know be a vessel for that story for a
woman and it felt very inspiring what do
you know about me
you hardly know me and all this sword
wants is death if you love it so much
you take it that is the sort of your
people it is your honor to wield it I
mean and watching the show that is one
thing I kept thinking is on the one hand
it's this fantastical world and I think
it will give people a bit of a mental
escape that they need right now but then
on the other hand it does deal with
these issues that are still all around
us about people being ostracized for who
they are and I wondered how much you
thought about that when selecting the
project and when filming it and how much
you're kind of reflecting on the timing
of its release right now um well you
know I I signed on very early and it was
because I loved the story and it was
funny because I wasn't necessarily
looking to do a TV series because
they're they're gargantuan projects and
but I knew that it it had to be
something right and this just felt so
right and I think it's been interesting
because as we were telling the story we
were aware that you know we want this
world to feel relevant and be true to
what it is and I think some of the best
fantasy is able to be relevant but also
be in escape and I think now more than
ever cursed kind of fits that box
because of the social consciousness and
because of the discussions that we're
having all over the world
so you love fantasy I don't know if you
loved you know shows like of course Game
of Thrones which are uh were you fans of
those and do you think that this show
will give that audience a craving filled
I am I mean I'm such a fan of fantasy I
having now met Frank Miller who is like
an absolute legend and also Tom wheeler
I I don't know how to call myself a nerd
now because they are just on such and I
say that with them that the most respect
that I could possibly garner it's they
just they know that world so well and
I'm I'm just a humble lover and enjoy of
that genre but you know I say that you
know that includes Game of Thrones that
includes Lord of the Rings all of that
I've really loved and it's interesting
because I think while we were filming it
and while people were even try
describer it's it's actually quite
difficult because when you think of each
of those really memorable epic sort of
fantastical pieces they all have that
they're all very um they all really have
their own stamp on what that is and what
their story is
and I think cursed in a similar way it
it's hard to describe because it also
has its own stamp on what this story is
you know it's very fantastical and and
thriller and action-packed but it's also
really grounded and rooted and magical
so it would be interesting to see how
people compare it if they compare it or
just how people will respond to it yeah
I mean this show is very different than
other projects that you've done what was
it like to figure out how to ride horses
the right way how to wield the sword in
a dress all that training and maybe what
was the hardest part of it well I'm I'm
a former athlete I trained as a swimmer
for nearly 10 years and so I was really
excited to dive into this and to use my
body for a role because I'd never done
that before okay
dive in thank you appreciate that quite
literally dive in um you know and you I
think you always wish you had more time
with these things and I would love to
you know explore that those areas and
those skills more because they really
are they require so much training but
you know I was really excited to to get
headfirst into that and I enjoy kind of
throwing myself into the physical
element of the show and it was in we had
I think four weeks before the show
started and then it was kind of like
okay you're on your own and as soon as
we started filming we just went until
until we stopped basically and I think
you know there were different challenges
within within filming there are always
challenges whenever you shoot anything
but this was such an epic and grand
scale and we were also doing it for such
a lot of time you know we were supposed
to have hiatuses or breaks and we had no
breaks we went ten months straight
through and I think that is such a
testament to the crew and to the cast
because we really needed to work
together and I I'm trying to think of
like the hardest day on set but even
when I think
like the hardest day on set it was still
really cool and if it was challenging it
was just something that we all bonded
over and later became funny if I had to
say I'd probably say one of NIM ways
most epic fight scenes which we shot on
the hottest day the UK has ever had
which was I think 44 degrees and then
which is I don't know like 100 105 and
then we were under lights I was wearing
three layers of leather and everyone
else was basically wearing red blankets
and it was just like oh and it was worse
season so I would like roll around in
fake blood and then someone's job after
every take was to pick the wasps off of
my costume which sounds crazy look it
sounds crazy but it was that fun and we
all really put together sorry the finale
what was your reaction when you read
that finale script and what would you
tease for fans about what's to come for
those characters in in upcoming seasons
I mean I mean firstly I feel like we
just have to say I'm just so excited and
I know everyone is just to let this you
know out into the world and we're really
you know we worked so hard on this first
season that I think we're just really
excited for everyone to see this first
season but I'd say it it ends on a
cliffhanger for a lot of the characters
figuratively and literally and I I think
there's a we've only really just seen
the tip of the iceberg these Arthurian
legends are so grand and I just I feel
like in a way it's just the start of
very many journeys I don't know I don't
know how to tease it without ruining it
for people
[Music]